Now Niagara offers a number of content examples that shows you how to do pretty much anything
you could ever want to do.
And the reason I'm bringing them up is these can act as some really great learning content.
And the examples that I'm talking about are Niagara particles, Niagara advanced and Niagara
fluids.
Now in Niagara particles, you're going to learn the very basics of Niagara.
It's going to show you how to do simple sprite and static mesh emitters.
There's GPU beams as well as emitters with multiple renderers.
And then showing you how to do things like simple collision or texture sampling, playing
audio and alignment and a few other things.
Niagara advanced, you're going to find a variety of ways that you can interact with
Niagara.
There are simulation stages, reading and writing to rendered targets or sampling from a skeletal
mesh or a GPU buffer.
There's also using attributes and distance field traversal.
You can also see some examples on bird flocking, 3D grid support, as well as component rendering,
exporting particles to blueprints and even sampling from dynamic distance fields.
Now Niagara fluids, this is where you're going to find a variety of emitters that can be
used to simulate smoke and liquids in real time.
Examples here included are gas and liquid, quality versus performance, light interaction,
particles infection, there's going to be camera facing smoke and fire, as well as 3D
smoke and fire.
So let's just pop over to the end of really quick and take a look at some of these.
So first off, hit control space and we're going to go to our maps folder here and the
content examples, NI and NIA and there is our Niagara particles.
So let's just double click on this to open it up and have a look at it.
So it's going to start over here and then as we go to the right, the particles are going
to get more and more complex.
So the examples again start off here, we're going to go with our sprite and then there
is a mesh and then as we go on, we're doing GPU and sprite facing.
So all of these really, really fantastic examples that you can see here that goes all the way
down here to a mesh orientation versus rotational force.
Next we're going to have our advanced one.
I'm not going to save that.
And in our advanced, we start again over here at looking at our render targets and then
going all the way over till we get to sampling from our dynamic sampling from our distance
field right here.
And there's tons of just different examples that we can use here for anything that we
would really want.
This is really cool.
This is the start of a structural support.
So some of this stuff as it starts to come undone, everything is going to start to fall
down in different stages.
So there's just really great examples that we can use here.
Last but not least Niagara fluids.
So open this one up and have a look at it.
Now Niagara fluids is quite expensive.
So if you're running with lots of programs open, you might need to close some to get
this to run.
But again, as we start here, we're going to go for something very simple like this is
a 2D gas and liquid simulation.
And then we have a 3D one right next to it.
You can see here there's quality versus performance.
There's fire.
Some of these do require that you come up here and press play.
I just am recording.
So I want to make sure that let's just try and simulate and see if that can help us.
I might actually have to press play.
And there we go.
Get up close to some of this.
I think some of this I have to get really close to it in order for it to work.
There we go.
So there's some fire rendering.
It's working with the lighting.
There's a little bit of lighting offset there.
You can see the particles are changing colors.
A lot of really, really great and cool stuff here.
So definitely worth checking out.
Now one of the last things that I want to talk about before we go on is every part of
the content examples also contains information about what is going on.
So if I do go to one of these and I open it up, I'm going to see comments about what is
going on and why this is set up in the way.
And again, this is why this works for such a good learning resource is I can not only
have a look at stuff.
You know, if I come in here, maybe look at something like maybe we grab this one.
So let's hit control E and then I come in here and it looks like I grabbed a bad one
for a let's go into our particles here because I know that these ones are.
Let's look at that one right there.
Maybe hit a control E and there we go.
So this one has a little bit more information inside of it as the fluids are documented
on the website.
Again, we can open up a lot of these and we're going to see inside of them a lot of information
about how we can use these or shouldn't say how we can use it, but why these.
Particles work in the way that they do and things that we need to be aware of when we
are using them.